it's picture perfect and we've got
baseball on our minds the tigers and
white sox square off in the first of
three this weekend and we
are with the folks outside we are in
right field
tarek scuba on the mound for the tigers
screened one record in his last four
105 career strikeouts most in the first
20 career games in tigers history
and a lot of that has to do with this
fastball more fastballs for strike
here's the 3-0 to your mean mercedes
and he draws a four-pitch walk
as mokata checks his swing did he go the
answer is no according to our first base
umpire andy fletcher and it's
back-to-back walks with
the 1-0
on a line nice play at third base they
can't double them up
both mercedes
and moncada advance
the one-two he struck him out
lucas giolito on for his 13th start his
era 388 certainly respectable so is 87
strikeouts in 69 and two-thirds only 24
walks
he's got six hits over his last three
games and he hits one sky-high
on the infield just into the outfield
grass actually is anderson behind second
change up
sky high into center that very expansive
glenn in center for adam engel
for round number two
in the air left field
well hit but vaughn has room and a
majestic third out
adam engel picked up his first hit of
the year it was a home run last night
that's lined to left and it is up and
over oh my goodness a dagger from adam
angle and it's one-nothing socks
in the blink of an eye that got up and
out that thing just took off not a real
surprise because he is really strong
the 1-2 swing in a minute that's a good
slider down and in
took off and scribbles got him picked
off there it is cabrera down to scope
he'll run him back to jake rodgers
and jake rogers will make the play scuba
was over there but rogers wanted to get
in on the fun
payoff is right there strike three
changeup absolutely flummoxed him one
down that brings up nomar mazzara since
that last home run again you have to go
back to mid april
swinging a high fly ball left field deep
way back in left and go on a home run
no more mazara
gets one to elevate ties the game at one
here in the second well i think we just
mentioned you know what the power he has
due to elevate one and he elevated that
baby just over the fence and left
nine batters first two innings and at
three and two
is strike three change up disappeared on
rogers and the inning's over we are tied
at one
to second
mendic and anderson and a double play it
goes four to six to three and lucas will
certainly take that
that's into the mitt for strike three
scope goes down on a slider and we are
tied at one after three
it is on the way and he lines one to
right in the corner and it was a
fastball
abraya will make his way towards second
base he's got a double
bang he nailed it
well i mean it really is unlikely he's
gonna throw him three straight
change-ups first and third no outs and
here comes adam engel
on the ground to shortstop paradise for
scope and that is a double play no rbi
but the sox will take the lead abreu
scores it is two to one in the fourth
one two strike three good change that's
the one that dives out of the zone for
lucas
oscars in the spin cycle with the slider
two down
one and two
on the ground second base danny mendick
collects it and throws mazara out two
strikeouts and a ground out we will go
to the fifth
such a thoughtful gesture
3-2 lined into the right-field corner
should be a double mazzara will go pick
it up and it is a two-bagger for collins
now the number nine man mendic runner at
second nobody out
ground ball into center base hit great
read by collins he's going to come
around and score
danny mendick with an rbi single
sox lead 3-1
the 76th pitch of the night strikes out
tim anderson
sox lead three to one tigers bat in the
fifth
paradise will bat first
drives one deep left field it's gone
[Applause]
one out into the tigers bullpen a solo
bomb to make it three to chicago good
way to lead it up two on one away here
comes garcia
strike throw to first bounces away angle
got back and now vaughan's on his way to
third he will head home andrew vaughan
is there to the plate and now angle is
caught up between second and third
adam peels away for third
throw goes back behind him skubal is now
involved and here is the tag
high change swatted to center angle is
there and one gone
strike three on a slider that was a
tight slider strikeout number nine for
geo
two two on the way
a little tapper
anderson
abreu's got the pick oh my goodness
right there strike three middle middle
changeup farewell
2-2 clipped back to crochet and his
throw is just nasty and jose somehow
makes the pick
in the air right field and playable
garrett crochet
has six outs tonight
at comerica park four to two to the
ninth in the series opener
garcia drives one to the right center
field gap cameron dives and makes the
grab
that's a beauty
and liam hendricks who leads the
american league in the saves is on to
work tonight
tony la russe is coming out of the
dugout now
now let's see that's the groundskeeper
and here comes the tarps and i think
they're yeah they're going to put it on
and i mean it's pouring this
these conditions are
really bad at this point ready for the
bottom of the ninth a 47 minute rain
delay they get to bring the potential
tying run to the plate that brings up
daz cameron instead he swings it
deep right field
get up it's gone
he's first as a major leaguer
ties it
[Applause]
first and third one away 4-4 tie 10th
inning that brings up johan monkatta 2-0
monkata pops it up into left-center
field grossman's underneath mendic from
thirds gonna test him throw to the plate
not in time danny gets there it is five
to four socks in the top of the tenth
inning two on nobody out grossman one
hit in four tries tonight
[Music]
struck him out on a slider one down
here's harold castro first and second
now one out
[Music]
he struck him out well that leaves it up
to jonathan scope one two
up the middle danny mendick is on it and
the sox have won this ball game
what an adventure
a drenching a tiger comeback and a life
raft
from a sacrifice fly from joan monkatta